let's go ahead and address the elephant
in the room which is Sir horny Cole and
obviously spoilers I'll structure this
review with talking about the negatives
first and then branching into the
positive since they were scattered
around the episode I think this was the
first time that the writing left me
genuinely puzzled and I laughed a couple
times from how absurd some of the twists
were so let's preface the Kristen Cole
conundrum with the question of how long
has it been between episodes four and
five because have they been having sex
for like months to a year and Nana's
wife sir Christian is so head over heels
for an era it currently comes across as
not that much time has passed and we're
picking up relatively quickly to where
we left off in regards to their
quote-unquote relationship if they made
it clear that it's been quite a bit of
time through the dialogue then I could
excuse for Kristen's Obsession but
that's not the impression I got there
was no dialogue like oh our time
together for these last few months have
been dear to me or whatever to tell us
how long it's been instead sir Christian
comes off really strong and fast to the
point of it feeling ridiculous like oh
leave everything behind and screw the
iron throne and come live with me in
essos of course she's going to say no
you dumbass it's just so stereotypical
and trophy for him to say this and it
feels dumb for his character to go down
this blind love route unless if sir
Kirsten all along was pretty stupid but
he never gave off that impression and he
always seemed pretty sharp in observant
even when he does give in to his desires
he knows what he's doing is wrong but he
decides to do it anyways he's not just
diving into the deep end without knowing
the consequences right so to me it's
just weird for him to be telling renira
this then this leads into the dinner for
the wedding ceremony during the entire
duration of this scene sir Kristen Cole
for whatever reason has his helmet off
for the entire Feast despite all the
other kingsguard having their helmets on
in the background now this is actually a
very important factor for what happens
later so I don't know why sir Christian
has his off despite him saying he's on
on duty not only this but sir Christian
is just staring at Rainier with an upset
expression for a very long duration so
any dimwit with eyes could piece
together what he's feeling to me it just
comes across as the writers needing a
way for Joffrey to naturally figure out
that sir Christian is obsessed with
renera so they can have a contrived
confrontation and then after this I
guess sir Christian just breaks out of
nowhere and beats the life out of
Joffrey why didn't anyone stop him why
are the guards in the background just
standing there why is this entire
wedding turning into a violent mosh but
after sir Christian attacks one person
what is happening right now there's so
many aspects about this whole scenario
that just doesn't make sense to me now
the issue isn't the presentation that is
supposed to be intentionally confusing
due to the perspective we're witnessing
the event from but more of the logic
behind everything and the character
motivations also is he still technically
a King's Guard after this whole scenario
shouldn't they be putting him in holding
there's so much confusion around all of
this and I desperately need them to
address this in the next episode
although I kind of doubt that's going to
happen since they seem to be doing a
major time Jump I've seen some counter
arguments that the kingsguard have high
Authority and no one questions their
judgment so sir Kirsten doing this is
passable because he can say that Joffrey
pulled a knife on rhaenyra which firstly
sir Christian is already upset that he's
damaging his honor so lying on top of
everything would theoretically make
things worse and secondly there are
dozens of witnesses close by that could
easily detest and he claims that sir
Kristen makes in the books Kristen
apparently kills Joffrey in tournament
combats and to me that seems much more
natural than blatantly executing him in
front of dozens of Lords that portrays
Kristen as being unstable and crazy I
feel like they need to clarify things a
bit and see some of the ramifications
and character reactions to what just
happened but it seems like that's not
going to be the case even the scene
after this where sir Christian is about
to kill himself suddenly was jarring
what is going on with my boy that I
loved is Ranier so amazing in the sheets
that sir Christian is losing his mind
over her and killing himself as if this
is some kind of Shakespearean play Then
Allison randomly walks in and interrupts
him right before he's about to end it
all like what what a coincidence and
great timing this is such a contrived
scenario to make us think that he's
actually about to kill himself just so
that she can walk in and stop him the
writing took a major downturn for the
last 10 minutes even before all this
where Allison was questioning him about
renira potentially having sex he
instantly turns into a [ __ ] she didn't
even finish what she was saying and
Kristen immediately had missed
everything like what the hell man sir
Kristen went from a character that I
really liked to someone who's literally
doing in any percent speedrun in ruining
his life so yeah everything surrounding
sir Christian is really bothering me so
let's move on and talk about some of the
positives the opening scene in the veil
was really gorgeous and I love that they
are filming in relocations and aren't
reliant on the volume lady Raya for the
short screen time that she had seemed
like a comet in an independent character
ashamed that Damon took her out of the
show so quickly which this is kind of a
nitpick but has Damon been standing here
waiting for her if so wouldn't that be
convenient for him to only run into her
and no one else or was he scouting in
the mountains or something and quickly
came down I don't know I'm thinking
about this more critically since sir
Christian kind of set me off but the
scene ends with a banger match cut so
any small flaw Is Forgiven
Otto Hightower has one quick dialogue
scene with Allison and is easily one of
my favorite scenes in the episode it's
emotionally charged throughout Otto is
further manipulating Allison by stoking
her fears and the information that
Ranier will possibly kill Allison's
children is heartbreaking I really hope
this isn't the last we see of Otto
because I adore the man a different
mirror succeeds in war will follow do
you understand hopefully when visceros
eventually passes away which is taking a
really long time since the man is
showing up in the next episode even with
the big time Jump Then Otto Hightower
can finally come back to King's Landing
going into the targaryens meeting up
with the valerions it feels ironic that
I like these setup scenes just as much
as the wedding payoff because there are
a lot of good moments here like the
subtle detail of laner's sword fighting
with his lover eluding early on that
he's gay the breathtaking coats that
Ranier and later are walking down and
both of the dialogue scenes within the
kingdom seeing cordless awkwardly step
around the succession conflict without
trying to be rude was very cute and the
tug of war between them trying to come
to an equal Arrangement was well written
the scene after this keeps the quality
going or rainy's makes a smart
observation that they are putting their
family in danger by teaming up with
renera it's kind of weird how ignorant
Corliss is towards that and even his
son's homophobia I'd assume he'd be a
bit smarter but I guess the man is
pretty obsessed with gaining more power
since he came from nothing in his blind
decided by those things then for the
last standout scene we have viserys's
monologue where he talks about his
regrets and his overall lasting image
it's heartbreaking to see this man on
his final leg suffering a painful death
but he's enduring all of this anguish so
he can try to be a better ruler and be
remembered despite all of his flaws and
making mistakes that's one aspect of his
character that's extremely commendable
he's so wholesome that he wants everyone
to love him and seeing him thinking
about different ways his life could have
played out is intriguing the
cinematography where the camera slowly
pushes in on visceros is a great touch
and really makes us empathize more with
him even Lionel strong during the scene
offers a good perspective where he says
it's better to have a peaceful role
instead of having a war and being
remembered for it that man is turning
out to be a great hand so far and seems
to be one of the only people not acting
selfishly at least so far it also makes
me wonder in the scene if the mazers are
intentionally failing at curing faceres
and and that tying into the whole
maester conspiracy of them disliking the
targaryens and overall having the power
to drastically affect people in power
because even if that's not the case you
can still kind of read into that going
back to the wedding dinner even though I
disliked the Christian Cole aspect of
the wedding there are still some other
great aspects that don't make the scene
really bad Damon and Allison being
showstoppers really spices up the
wedding and adds some conflict into the
mix especially Allison literally just
coming in to make a statement that she's
pissed off and means business and Damon
showing up increases the quality of any
scene in the show the moment between
Damon and Sir Gerald Royce Was Juicy in
which Damon essentially Uno reverse
cards sergelled wanting to have him
executed by countering with inheriting
all of Lady raya's Land Sergio's
reaction to that was golden and further
cements Damon as a cunning player in the
series then the overall attention to
detail was astounding with the set
decorations the amount of characters on
display and all of the interactions
between them shooting this scene must
have been a very daunting task I think
the execution of it ended up being
pretty good besides the circustin
portion of it obviously and before
ending the video it feels crazy to me
that we're already transitioning to the
older actors like it's only been five
episodes so far and we've gone through
years of their lives this feeling may be
more noticeable if we were watching
these episodes all at once but since
we're waiting a week between each
episode the time jumps may not feel as
noticeable but so far the pace feels a
bit jarring at times especially in the
case of Sir Christian Cole's
relationship with rainera because we go
from them having sex for the first time
two sir Kristen immediately shooting his
shot as if they've been lovers for a
long time regardless though the casting
director is working overtime and finding
outstanding actors to keep replacing
these characters even Lena valerion was
just replaced for this episode and in
the next one she's being replaced again
but overall I think the writing
surrounding Kirsten Cole was pretty
contrived and stereotypical and I
previously hoped they wouldn't go down
this road besides that one shortcoming
the episode was still really good and
thank you for watching let me know what
you thought about episode 5 in the
comments